make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
probably sound a little off this morning
kind of having one of my bad days those
are guys who have been around the
channel long enough really kind of know
what that means but we're picking up
with Thor issue number five right and
and in this series so far we kind of had
this scenario where you've had like the
black Walter right and all we knew about
the black winter was that it was this
kind of being that existed out there
that was capable of just seemingly
annihilating entire universes right our
first introduction to it was that it
seemed to wipe out the DC Universe it
wasn't explicitly stated but by the
nature of the characters that's kind of
what we saw and then Thoreau was
ultimately inducted as a Herald of
Galactus in order to destroy the black
winter and a lot of it was because
Galactus seemed to see his own death
from the black women which is what it
does it shows you how it is you're going
to die and in Thor effectively help
Galactus track down five different
planets all of which had a unique energy
signature that would allow Galactus to
consume those worlds in preparation for
boosting his power and facing off
against a black winter and so what this
does is this initially opens up with SIF
who has most of you guys know was the
one-time girlfriend of Thor who taken a
place of her brother Heimdall and is now
essentially the Asgardian who watches
everything unfold and for the most part
it's all kind of pandemonium right Thor
and Galactus facing off against the
black winter Thor has been absorbed at
this point alongside Galactus SIF can't
see him anymore
you've got beta ray bill who's still
recovering from his injuries where he
had the crap beat out of him by Thor
basically for doing nothing more than
standing in his way but jumping over to
Thor himself alongside Galactus the
fight against the black winter goes
exactly as you would expect right there
overwhelmed quite readily and they're
doing the best they can right by the the
funny things the black winter starts to
talk to Thor and it basically refers to
him as the the king of Asgard they got a
thunder so on and so forth so the black
winner knows who he is and then work a
lot just continues to try to fight the
black winner tells him to stop and it
says like calm down and initially kind
of approaches him as like a friend of
sorts right like I'm here to talk to you
like I'm here to understand what's going
on like that kind of a thing but like
immediately it's one of these things
where it becomes kind of like this
menacing force where it basically asks
Thor the question you know do you want
to see how you die and and for the most
part at that point in time like when
that happens it seizes control of
Galactus and then immediately takes over
Galactus and basically seems to kind of
shut down the power he has
the very least power he has is nowhere
near enough to defeat the black winner
which really shows us that like a
lightness his attempts to defeat this
this entity using all this energy that
he absorbed was really more of like a
guess right it was really more just an
estimation as to kind of the kind of
power he needed in order to win and then
Thor does what he can and so ultimately
Thor ends up kind of absorbed by the
black winner and then wakes up in this
almost kind of puzzle of sorts well you
got like the Penrose steps the steps to
go nowhere right that kind of a thing
and when that happens the black winner
still kind of speaks almost from the
shadows right kind of like this
ambiguous force and Thor kind of calls
them out right it's sort of like you
know like like face me like I want to
know who you are show me who you are and
it's almost kind of taunting right like
I offer you a truth when I offer you a
gift I offer you the ability to know
what your end is going to be when you
end up dying and so it's not really done
from a place of kindness it's done from
a place of just being a dick and so this
basically leads to Thor finally calling
out the black winner and the black one a
black winner up here's it shows up as
gore the god butcher and Thor
immediately begin to submit right his
idea is like I killed you you're
supposed to be dead that's not how this
works and that's kind of how the black
winter functions right it's not about
just a physical conflict it's
psychological warfare because following
that it changes into the being Loki
after that it changes into mangog and
then suddenly it becomes all the various
enemies of Thor right it becomes the the
the serpent across the world it becomes
Mephisto it becomes Doctor Doom the
juggernaut apocalypse Malekith basically
every foe that Thor has ever faced over
the course of his entire history and the
funny thing about this is that the black
winner makes this comment that these
would all have been the end of Thor the
word would have been killed in all these
various circumstances an uncanny
Avengers for example the first time the
Thor fights apocalypse that's how we end
up finding finding out that your horn
was magically enchanted Thor had to use
that in order to defeat apocalypse but
had that not happened Thor would have
been killed right apocalypse would have
overpowered him and would have
completely and totally destroyed him and
that's kind of how this is right that
the black winter kind of makes this
comment about how Thor was supposed to
have died so many times he was supposed
to die against the Beyonder he was
supposed to die against the serpent he
was supposed to die in Ragnarok he was
supposed to die at the hands of a
nihilist over and over and over again he
was supposed to have been killed right
and in a lot of ways he was he was
burned he was atomized crucified he was
totally completely and totally unmade
right in all these various
instances he was supposed to be totally
eliminated but by some manner he always
ended up coming back because there's
something out there and we're not really
giving you know we're not really told
this is a literal thing or a
metaphorical thing but there's someone
out there that's basically kind of
slithering through time changing things
up right killing his destiny on what
he's supposed to be or basically
breaking his fate that kind of a thing
you know and it's almost like you he's
sort of tossed like this slack winter
has a bit of knowledge out there if Thor
doesn't have and that kind of makes
sense if you're talking about an entity
powerful enough to basically be an
entire universe that it means it would
encompass the entirety of the universe
right so the past the present and the
future and so if that's the case then it
essentially means that this being would
have knowledge of all the past the
present and the future and so it would
actually know how Thor is going to die
and so where he's can you know
consistently being taunted and facing
off against all these foes that are
easily overpowering him right apocalypse
Serdar all these different guys Thor
does the only thing he can do he takes
all the energy that he has within
himself and within Mjolnir and basically
channels it into the god blast now for
those you guys who don't know the god
blast is the most powerful weapon and
Thor's arsenal right the most powerful
ability not really a weapon but the most
powerful ability he has right the
ability to channel all of his energy
into a single blow the power of the god
blast is enough that he can actually
damage a celestial with it you're
talking about an exceedingly high amount
of energy now it's also incredibly
exhausting the only thing that I would
say might rival the power of the God
blast might be like Thor's berserker
rage right as warriors madness where he
just loses all sense of self and just
kind of goes absolutely insane so
basically the same as Wolverines for
Wolverines berserker rage as wizard her
state right and so finally with Galactus
basically being freed by the help of the
God blast of Thor and then Thor himself
being freed this kind of forces the
black winter to essentially back off and
so Thor finally calls and says like like
I want to know who you are right like
show me who you are you know if you
believe that that you're that I'm afraid
of my end then you've missed your
mistake and right show me my end and see
if the own Sun blinks and the response
of the of the god winner is very well I
will show you your end but it's not
yours not yet and then he basically
appears ask Thor himself
when he appears as basically like an
evil dark version of Thor and that's
when Thor begins to realize this is what
Galactus saw that led him to making Thor
his Herald in the first place this evil
black winter version of himself
the idea that Thor would basically be
the undoing of Galactus that seemed to
be the case that Galactus himself was
going to die now it seems like a life
just may not have fully understood what
he was seeing I have a hard time
believing that but having the black
winter up here as Thor and then
seemingly saying something like I will
be your end would indicate that Thor
would be the one who would kill Galactus
doesn't really seem to be the case but
still you know Thor is kind of like okay
like enough of your talk it doesn't
matter what it is you're here for or
anything like that like if you're here
to be an enemy then we'll make an enemy
out of you and we'll destroy you
what is it that you actually want here
and it's kind of funny because Galactus
starts kind of explaining things and
saying yes you know you I saw you as my
end and all that kind of stuff and the
black winter basically reveals that's
not true
what Galactus has been telling Thor is
not true that none of what Galactus has
said is honest that in fact Galactus has
basically been trying to use Thor as a
means to end the black winter and the
reason why he's been trying to do that
is because of what the black winter is
here for the black winter is not here
for forward you know to conquer the
universe it's not here to destroy the
universe or anything of that sort the
black winter has been hunting across the
various universes that are out there for
the sole purpose of finding Galactus now
it is kind of strange right because when
it comes to Marvel Comics we know that
there are an infinite number of Galactus
is right one Galactus for every universe
that was covered in the Abraxas saga the
idea that every universe had at some
point in time a guy named Galan and by
whatever manner and whatever means that
universe came to an end
Galan merged with the sentience of that
universe and then was reborn into the
new universe as Galactus but the fact is
that like the whole Abraxas saga was
kind of swept under the rug by Marvel
that's one of those stories that you
read or it takes place animala just
ignores it forever more right and so
because they even really heard any kind
of reference to Abraxas or any of those
things so there's no reason to believe
that aside from maybe the version of
Galactus we saw in the Ultimate Universe
and whatever versions we may have seen
around the the multiverse that there
really is no Galactus or or Noah no
other verses are Galactus or we could
say this is Galactus prime right the the
relationship that the black winner has
this Galactus is unique and indeed it is
right the black winner says I'm here for
him for the one I spared for the one I
created for gallon of ha for Galactus my
Herald and so seemingly Galactus was at
one point a herald of the black winter
and the black winter has come to reclaim
his Herald he's come to reclaim what is
rightfully his but with that being said
guys whatever in this video
when again I apologize that it's not my
most exciting self there's kind of a lot
that I'm going through at the moment and
and it's it's I mean I'm not gonna lie
to you guys it's it's it's rough it's a
pretty rough spot you know it's a pretty
rough spot to be and I'm just I'm
struggling pretty hard right
so um so yeah we're gonna bring this
video to an end now we'll catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you